nothing is fair it's nothing has ever
been Fair I've if you've lived a life of
genuine hardship the first thing you
will learn is that nothing is ever Fair
I've never seen a fair fight on the
street I've never seen a fair
relationship I've never seen a person
lose his girlfriend or lose their
husband fairly I've never seen a fair
incident on the road when someone gets
crushed by a truck the world is a very
unfair place and humans come along and
we report this idea don't worry if we're
in charge we'll make it fair
nothing is ever ever fair and the human
inclination is to win as it should be
and the more powerful you are and the
higher the stakes the higher inclination
to win as it should be this is human
nature you wouldn't be able to put
yourself in a position of power if you
thought any other way so if you're going
to sit there and accept the basis that
we're going to cheat in a basic
basketball game now people cheat in
football games and cheap people cheat in
poker and people cheating all this
[ __ ] and then say no but they're not
going to cheat to control the world and
you're asinine it's all fine it's all
cheap